[Music]
if you like sex I think I know my crowd
[Music]
that was sad no good news if you like
sex researchers have discovered that
sexual activity creates new connections
in your brain actually makes you smarter
that's right yes that's right this is an
article a lot of people been talking
about it's sex makes you smarter one of
our writers saw this story and had some
thoughts about it so let's bring him out
please welcome Deon Cole
[Music]
thanks Conan so having lots of sex makes
you smarter well that can only mean one
thing you're looking at Deon Einstein
okay well what what are you talking
about
it's classic mack daddy
[Applause]
Chris what do you mean by classic
macdaddy fronting well Dion was citing
the study to claim that his frequent
sexual activity made him smarter but can
you really copulate your way to higher
intelligence
let's take a look it takes a thousand
hookups to raise your IQ by just one
point four Dion to match Einstein's
intelligence Dion would have to raise
his IQ thirty points by having sex
thirty thousand times for a man Dion's
age that's four bangs a day to do this
Dion would have to have enormous
testosterone levels high stamina and
possibly backup testicles in his abdomen
and lymph nodes plus a repetitive hyper
manic sex technique that leaves little
room for true intimacy but over time
enough brain neurons would be connected
to take Dion from this to this
[Applause]
that's fascinating is so is that what
you meant to say Dion
more or less yeah okay thank you Chris
Parnell be on call
very nice